Elon Musk a man who turns science
fiction into reality a Pioneer a
disruptor a Visionary The Man Behind
SpaceX Tesla and neurolink from electric
cars Define the fossil fuel industry to
reusable rockets that promise a future
of interstellar travel Elon Musk as a
revolutionary let's talk numbers a net
worth of $259 billion founder of six
companies and a man who sent over 100
Rockets to space he's not just wealthy
he's using his resour resources to
tackle climate change explore space and
even unlock the human brain but it's not
just about numbers or Innovations it's
about a man who sees failure as a
stepping stone who challenges not just
Industries but human limitations Awards
absolutely times person of the year
Forbes the world's most powerful people
and times 100 most influential people
what fuels this man what principles
guide them today we delve into Elon
musk's top 10 rules of success these are
the principles that trans transformed
the young entrepreneur into a global
change maker pay attention this isn't
just a list it's a blueprint for World
Changers it's a road map designed by a
man who's been on both sides of success
and failure he's been a subject of books
articles and studies not just for his
business Acumen but for his ability to
challenge scientific Norms his work has
Global implications he's pushing for a
sustainable future on Earth while also
laying the groundwork for Life on Mars
behind the genius is a man a father of
11 a mentor to thousands and an
inspiration to Millions his journey is a
testament to the resilience of the human
spirit this isn't just a video it's a
catalyst prepare to redefine what you
thought was possible here's our take on
Elon musk's top 10 rules of success
enjoy what would you say to young people
that want to change the world that have
big Ideas what advice could you give I
would say you know go do it um you just
just go out there and and and do it um
the I mean the biggest thing I think
people uh fail to do is that they they
they're they're too afraid to try things
you know that they shouldn't be afraid
of of of failing and and they should
just go go and do it did you fail at
anything that you tried I've I've lost I
mean I've not lost a war but I've lost
battle certainly I mean the first three
um flights of of the Falcon one rocket
uh they crashed so wow that must have
been a big bummer it it was a big bummer
you cry no rule number two be optimistic
I'm generally of the view
philosophically philosophically that
it's better to be optimistic and wrong
occasionally than pessimistic and right
um you know uh you I think you want to
look on the bright bright side of things
and um and I'm a little worried that
um uh young people today maybe sometimes
are a little pessimistic about the
future
but like I I'd like to just assure
people that so long as we are not
complacent we will solve the climate
solve the climate crisis and we will
solve these issues um we OB need to take
them seriously and work hard to solve
them they will be solved um and that
people should be optimistic about the
future and and work to make that
optimistic future real you know they say
that the best way to predict the future
is to create it
um and so if you take the actions
necessary for there to be a good future
then we will have a good future um and
um so I'd encourage people to be
optimistic take the actions that will
create a good future and we will have
one rule number three read more and talk
to smart people I know you're a huge
reader um but from a um a lifelong
learning perspective constantly trying
to add to your toolkit so that you're
you know a better leader a better CEO
are there recommendations that you have
for the audience about those kinds of
things that you do to keep yourself
mentally
sharp well I read a lot less these days
than I used to when I was a kid I was
read all the time
um I mean mostly subscribe to Scientific
periodical like um you know like the The
Daily News I find to be a lot of noise
um and just very negative uh so I
generally try to not read The Daily News
that much um because generally
newspapers try to seem to be trying to
answer the question what is the worst
thing that happened on Earth
today Earth's big okay there's a lot of
people something terrible happened every
single day guaranteed big big plan also
something great happened but don't don't
answer that question um so that's the
Daily News just tends to make more
measurable I think like the um science
science and te technology periodicals
are quite interesting um and usually you
know if there's something some new
discovery it'll be in there
um so and you I find Twitter
enlightening at times you know uh learn
learn up B there
um and and talking to smart people all
the time uh is very helpful um because
that can be a distillation of of of
interesting things that are going on
um and you know certainly like try to
ask people like for the car like what
are we doing wrong you know what can we
fix what can we make better and they
usually just want to tell me oh it's
great you it like sure I understand but
what's wrong with it and like what can
we make better you know this is this
theory of like how do we be that's wrong
rule number four push through hardships
starting a company is is a very tough
thing um there's a friend of mine bully
who whose phrase is you know starting a
company is like um staring into the
abyss and and eating glass um so uh you
should certainly expect that it is going
to be very hard um it's going to be
harder than getting a job somewhere uh
by by a pretty good margin um and um the
odds of
you losing the money that you've
invested or your friends have invested
is is pretty high I mean that's just
those are just basic facts um
so uh if if you don't mind things being
really hard and and and higher risk then
uh starting a company is is a good idea
otherwise it's it's probably unwise uh
and we'll certainly stress you
out um so I think you have to be pretty
pretty driven to make it happen um
otherwise you will just make yourself
miserable
um and then and then in in creating
company as I said a moment ago it's just
uh you just want to really say how do
you make the best product or service
possible um you know companies that
don't make good products or service
Services just shouldn't exist also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five be excited about
the future this is not about like trying
to enrich myself um I do not live a life
of cons conspicuous
consumption um I work you know very long
hours and but I think I think what
chesla is doing is important to the
Future um and that's that's why I keep
doing it um and I think you know it's
it's something I I think is
uh Tesla increases the probability that
the future will be good for Humanity and
and then for SpaceX
um I think I think uh it's important
that we take the actions like that we
become a space bearing civilization and
a multiplet species this is an exciting
inspiring future you know you need to
have things that when you wake up in the
morning you're like you're excited about
the future why live if if it's all about
solving problems or being able Why Live
um so there got to be things that are
that are inspiring that like you know
get you in the heart and I think space
is one of those things so you know look
at the Apollo program and you know sing
sending people to the Moon in '
69 and wasn't that a great thing for of
humanity great thing and if you ask
people like one of what are some of the
greatest things that Humanity has ever
done that would be one of them rule
number six learn learn at every
opportunity I think you really want to
try to learn at every opportunity and um
you know it's it's great to um read
books and talk to interesting people
and uh learn as much as possible um and
um you know I suppose it was
the I know Plato or someone who said um
or maybe attributed to
um if I if I know anything is that I
know
nothing um and so
essentially uh just taking that attitude
that um really we wish to be less
foolish over
time um but I think it's actually if you
accept the premise that you were a
fool then TR all to AOL to some degree
then I think that and you wish to be
less foolish then
that's a I think that's a good approach
you know and um and this this avoids
that maximizes your feedback and and
your ability to learn um as soon as you
start thinking you know too much and
people can't teach you things that's
when you start getting very
dumb um so U yeah I always try to learn
learn new things and um and and being
able to talk to interesting people and
and you can often learn more by the
questions that are asked than the
answers that are given rule number seven
have a sense of humor I mean generally I
think we should be aiming
for like a
positive society and uh you know that it
should be okay
to you know be humorous uh like you know
like we should we should like like Wess
basically wants to make comedy
illegal which is not cool we've
experienced a little bit of that I mean
Chappelle like what the flower bed I
mean trying to shut down Chappelle come
on man that's crazy um
so um you know so do do we want a
humorless society that is simply Rife
with
condemnation uh and hate basically uh
and no forgiveness right
yeah at its heart Wess is
divisive um
exclusionary um and hateful it's it's it
basically gives mean people a reason a a
a a a it gives them a shield to be to be
mean and cruel armored in false virtue
rule number eight don't be scared of
Aging you've been poking fun at people
for their age quite a bit and I wanted
to have a sense of do you not plan to
age how are are you combating aging is
there some secret technology we don't
know about that you are got I'm not
aware of any secret technology to combat
aging I don't know that we should really
try to live for a super long time it is
important for us to die because most of
the times people don't change their mind
they just die if we live forever then we
might become a very aifi Society where
new ideas cannot succeed but I'm not I'm
not poing fun at aging I'm just saying
you know if if we've got people in very
important positions that have to make
decisions that are critical IAL to the
security of the country then they need
to have sufficient presence of mind and
cognitive ability to to make those
decisions well because the whole country
is depending on them well I thought you
might say psychedelics were your your
your way of of not aging but um I don't
think dropping acid makes you age
less
so I think drugs probably make you age
more not less rule number nine always
keep an open mind we're wondering if he
could do us a quick solid and accept
Jesus is your lord and
savior
on um personal Lord and you know it's a
quick
prayer
uh I mean let's just say like I agree
with the principles that Jesus advocated
um and that the you know there are some
some there's great wisdom in what in in
the teach teachings of of Jesus uh and I
agree with those
teachings um and things like tone the
other cheek
are are very important because as
opposed to an eye for an ey um an eye
for an eye leads everyone blind
so
forgiveness you know is important
and um treating people as you would wish
to be treated love thy neighbor as
thyself very important so it's like a 60
70% yes as Einstein would
say I believe in the god of
Spinosa um
so um but hey if um you know if if if
Jesus is is uh saving people I mean I I
I wouldn't stand in his way you know
like I'll be sure I'll be saved for not
anual number 10 the last home before
some very special bonus Clips is have
fun what's going on with you in Twitter
I am a Twitter addict I say the wrong
things all the time what is someone
explained it to me was very close to you
saying it's your release
valve this is where you feel
better yeah I think I said some people
some people use their hair to express
themselves I use
Twitter do you regret any of it or not
you are kind of
prominent yeah I mean sure walk us
through when you decide to do a a tweet
you go no no no well I think about it
for hours do you and I consult with my
strategy
team you you just literally go yeah yeah
yeah one of or maybe I'm wasted in that
gone let me shoot myself on the foot bam
now let me shoot myself on the foot bam
yeah that describe some of my tweets
yeah our primary goal is is to
create the technology necessary to get
people to Mars in the absence of which
not you know it's some academic um so we
don't want to get too distracted from
our primary mission of we we we got to
make it at least possible to to go to
Mars um and we we want to uh do so as
soon as possible um and make uh access
to Mars as widely available as possible
as affordable as possible so that if
somebody wants to go they can
um so that that's that's our primary
Mission um I mean there are many good
causes in the world but we got to be
careful that we do not try to um take on
too many
uh I mean there there are many noble
missions but we we we have to pick our
battles and say okay let's just make
sure we we get this done um and uh
because nobody else is doing it and I
mean if if uh if SpaceX doesn't do it
I'm not
sure how how it will happen I think this
this is the at least right now SpaceX is
the the only hope so we we got to get
this done and it's far from done I mean
it's we got a lot long way to go um yeah
I starlink in terms of providing inter
internet connectivity to U people that
really don't have it or it's very
expensive I think will be helpful in um
empowering a lot of people who are
disempowered today so I think that's a
good thing too I me I'm generally of the
view philosophically philosophically
that it's better to be optimistic and
wrong occasionally than pessimistic and
right um you know uh I think you want to
look on the right right side of things
and um and I'm a little worried that
um uh young people today maybe sometimes
are a little pessimistic about the
future but like I I'd like to just
assure people that so long as we are not
complacent we will solve the climate we
solve the climate crisis and we will
solve these issues um we obviously need
to take them seriously and work hard to
solve them they will be solved um and
that people should be optimistic about
the future and and work to make that
optimistic future real you know they say
the the best way to predict the future
is to create it um and so if you take
the actions necessary for there to be a
good future then we will have a good
future um and um so I'd encourage people
to be optimistic take the actions that
will create a good future and we will
have one what was going through your
mind how how amazed were you to see your
Roadster up there with star man uh just
cruising along with the blue planet and
how long will we be getting live views
do you think from the car well I think
it looks so ridiculous and
impossible um and you can tell it's real
because it looks so fake
honestly like we' have way better CGI if
it was
fake
um and you know the the colors all look
look kind of weird in space there's no
atmospheric occlusion you know you know
like everything looks too crisp um and
um but we know we didn't really test any
of those materials for you know is it
space hardened or whatever you know so
it just has the same seats that like
normal car has it's just literally a
normal car in
space which I kind of like the absurdity
of
that um and if you look closely there's
on the dashboard there's a tiny Roadster
with a tiny
Spaceman So Hot Wheels made a Hot Wheels
Roadster and and a friend of mine uh um
suggested hey why don't you put that Hot
Wheels road so with a tiny SP man on the
you know the car too like that'd be cool
sure so we did that um I mean it's kind
of silly and fun but I I think I think
that's you know silly fun things are
important um and normally for new rocket
you know they launch like a block of
concrete or something like that I mean
that's so
boring um and I think that's just the
imagery of it is something that's going
to get people excited around the
world
um and it's still tripping me out I mean
I'm tripping Bulls here I think AI
safety is a really big deal um and we
should have some regulatory agency that
is overseeing uh AI safety
um um but there is not yet currently any
such thing and and just generally any
kind of regulatory agency done by the
government will usually takes years to
put in place place um
so
um you know after uh the population
collapse issue I think AI safety is
probably the second biggest um threat to
the future of civilization
um and
um
yeah like I said I'm not quite sure what
to do with it um I mean Tesla is
arguably the the world's biggest robot
maker cuz like we have basically semi
semi-autonomous cars that will
ultimately be fully autonomous um and we
are building a humanoid robot that will
be basically like um like like the car
but with legs um
so um and I I kind of uh held off on
doing that for a while
because you know I I certainly don't
want to hasten the AI apocalypse but
clearly with look at Boston Dynamics and
and like this humanoid robots are going
to happen so um they're really going to
happen with or without Tesla so it's
like Tesla got a little bit more I mean
a lot more ability to ensure uh robotics
safety and AI um and I'll will try my
best to to do that my question is about
failure so I was just wondering what are
you trying at the moment or what do you
think you'll attempt in the future that
you're not expecting to succeed
it
well I think I think I'm going to stay
on on um electric cars and and Rockets
for a while um and
uh yeah it was actually never never my
intent to to run Tesla I I I kind of
because running two companies is quite
quite a burden actually
um um I I you know it's it's sometimes I
run into people who who who who think oh
if you're see Co of the company then
they then they sort of Imagine
themselves if they were COO of the
company they would Grant themselves lots
of vacation um and do lots of fun things
it's like that doesn't work quite work
work that
way um what you actually get is a
distillation of the the the worst things
going on in the
company it's like um and uh anyway so I
I I that the idea of taking on something
more is uh is is very frightening um
but uh I mean possibly at some point in
the future certainly not the near term
there are uh I think there's there's um
an opportunity to create um an electric
jet essentially um and and I do think
one could create an electric jet that
that um is really exciting something
that would be supersonic vertical
takeoff and Landing pure electric um and
just just a a vaguely forward um I think
I think that's that's a just think I'm
quite confident it's doable um provided
that there's a uh a rough doubling of
the energy density um in in batteries or
capacitors you basically around around
the 500 wat per kilogram level is where
it starts to make sense um and then
there's um I I do think there's the
possibility of kind of a a fifth mode of
Transport uh which I've talked
about kind of mentioned tangentially uh
which is uh
I I call kind of the the hyperloop um
and
um you
know I I i' like to sort of publish
something about that maybe in the next
month or two um once Tesla's at steady
state production um and and I want to
flesh it out a little bit to so that um
and and and pre- address some of the
rebuttals that people will come up with
um rather than just sort of put it out
there and then Happy have the rebuttal
occur and and and have an unaddressed
rebuttal
um but um I guess a way to think of it
as um it's like a cross between uh a
Concord and a rail gun supposed to be 20
years old right now where would you
start your path
from mean if I was literally just so if
I was just a 20-year-old right now in
2021 in
[Music]
2021 from where would you
start um
H well I mean assuming that I'm still a
technologist
then I think
there's um a lot of
opportunity in synthetic uh
RNA yeah um the you know the vaccines
that were developed apart from that the
ones that were done by bio inch and um
Berna um are really the beginning of
what I call digital medicine or medicine
and software and I think that's I would
say what's the single biggest
opportunity I see right now it's
probably um synthetic RNA um and uh the
potential for revolutionizing medicine
in that way um there's also artificial
intelligence um there's one of my
favorites that which is
tunnels um we need a lot of tunnels to
address the traffic in in major cities
um and then there's obviously the the
continued electrification of Transport
uh with aircraft and boats um in
addition to
cars um let's see
the there many other things that will
come up as well
so I I think we live at a very exciting
time uh you know if you look at the
whole history of the world and you know
Humanity this is a time of the greatest
technological growth in history um and
it seems to be accelerating there was a
bunch of very misleading stuff that was
published
uh by
propublica um and really that was some
sort of trickery
and really that they did themselves no
good service by by by doing that
um uh first of all with respect to the
government contracts that that uh SpaceX
wins uh our aspiration is to do the most
for the least and if you look at all the
contracts we've won um we've won them
because we're the best price we have a
better service at a lower price they
won't just handed to to us I don't think
they were that's what I'm saying in fact
you called me and said we finally got in
after years of sort of this back Slappy
I think it's a great thing that is a
great thing absolutely I mean in the for
the lunaa just taking that as one
example um uh our bed was half the price
of the blue origin uh Loi uh bed half so
for a vehicle that does basically 10
times more or eight times more perhaps
um our price was half okay and NASA has
a mandate to get back to the moon so we
save taxpayers like $3 billion relative
to that contract um so I think that's
that's a good thing there's sometimes a
debate about going to Mars One Way um
and whether that makes things easier and
I think for the initial fights perhaps
but long term to get the cost down you
need the spacecraft back whether the
people come back is irrelevant uh uh but
but but you must have the ship back uh
because those those things are expensive
so so anyone who wants to return can
just jump on
um so that that's but but until a few
years ago I wasn't sure that success was
one of the possible outcomes and now I
now I think I'm quite sure that success
is possible of course there's a long way
between possible and making it real but
I I believe it's possible as sour of my
inspiration I'd say is um somewhat
philosophical um the
um so I think the
the uh the thing we should be aiming for
is uh increasing the scope and scale of
human
civilization um so as to
best uh ask the qu the right questions
for the answer which is reality um or
the
Universe um and so if you accept that uh
premise then and we should work to
ensure the long-term survival and
prosperity of
humanity uh of Consciousness and we
should uh seek to
extend that Consciousness beyond Earth
to other planets eventually other star
systems
um that is the nature of My Philosophy
you did one great dat about time saying
time is the uh currency which I thought
was beautiful time is the ultimate
currency yes um no matter what resources
you have you can't wind back the clock
it's true yeah going into the future our
goal with Tesla is to uh keep refining
the technology increasing the scale of
production um and um and and make a mass
Market electric car uh that that that
almost anyone can afford um that's
that that's step three on the strategy
so step one was was um high price low
volume step two mid price mid volume
step three low price high volume so
we're sort of at step two and now we we
want to progress to to step three as as
soon as possible there's another
important principle which is that um you
really want uh everyone to be a chief
engineer so everyone is chief engineer
means that people need to understand the
the system at a high level to know uh
what they uh when they are making a a
bad optimization uh it's like like when
they are like uh
say like this we've done this many times
we've like put immense effort into
reducing the uh engine Mass but not uh
but hardly any effort into reducing uh
propellent residuals or or like order of
magnitude less effort into reducing
propellent residuals and then you end
you land with a literal ton of unused
fuel what is is the one thing that has
surprised you about your
life oh one thing wow well I certainly
I'm surprised about the whole thing
honestly I certainly didn't expect to be
to be uh for any of these things to
happen honestly
um yeah I I just knew I knew I wanted to
be involved in technology um and uh in
fact the only reason I started a company
back in '95 an era company was because I
couldn't get it there were only a few
internet companies and I couldn't get a
job at any of them so um I tried to get
a job at at Netscape um and uh sent my
resume in I tried hanging out in the
lobby but I was too shy to talk to
anyone and and then I was like okay well
I guess I'll have to start a company cuz
I can't get a job anywhere here's
another question um from a Tesla
owner why is there no coat hook in the
back
yeah he says he or she says you can
design a rocket but you forgot the coat
hooks well I didn't actually forget it I
just I intentionally didn't like it so I
didn't put it there um like the
Aesthetics of it really bothered me but
um I know you know obviously some people
disagree with that decision um but I
think I think we might have
um a retroactive fix for that if
somebody has the panoramic roof uh which
is to to basically have a hook on the
the bow section in the middle of the
roof um and then the then the your code
could hang down in the second row
passenger footwell which is actually
slightly better than having a coat hook
uh that's stuck on the side of the car
um so I think we'll probably do that
um yeah it sure is important to get the
the rules right um and um you know it's
sort of uh in in terms of legis of an
executive actions um you know it's sort
of like um you you think of say like
professional sports or something if you
if you don't have the rules right if
there isn't uh uh you know um if if if
if the game isn't set up properly it's
not going to be a good game um so it's
really important to get the ru the rules
right um now I think it's it's worth
noting that I think still um in the
United States the rulle are still better
than anywhere else um um but um the you
know it's it's very easy to put
something in place which is an inhibitor
to to innovation without realizing it um
so in terms of um the regulatory
environment uh uh it's It's always
important to bear in mind that uh
regulations uh are Immortal um and they
they they never die unless somebody act
actually goes and kills them and then
they they get a lot of momentum so a lot
of times regulations can be put in place
for all the right reasons um but then
nobody goes back and gets rid of them
afterwards when there no longer make
sense um you know that uh and there used
to be a rule in the early days when
people were concerned about automobiles
cuz that was a pretty scary thing to see
a carage just going wrong by itself you
know you never know what those things
might do um so there were like where you
had to in a lot of states where you had
to carry a lantern in front of the
automobile um and had to be like 100
Paces ahead of the automobile they to be
someone with a lantern on a
pole like okay but you should really get
rid of that regulation and they did you
know um really be awkward um so um so
just regulations even if done correctly
and for and being right at the time it's
always important to go back and and
scrub those you know periodically to
make sure they're still sensible and
they're still serving the greater good
the proposed Mars Expedition um what how
exactly do you plan on making it cost
efficient sure um well now that is that
is indeed a tricky problem
um I mean I feel reasonably possible
that
um that success is at least one of the
possible outcomes
um like this is a I mean this is pretty
important when you're trying to do
something it's like well can can that be
one of the outcomes I wasn't actually
confident about that until a few years
ago
um now I'm not saying we will get there
but I I I I I'm confident that it is at
least possible
um and the key to that is having a fully
reusable m transportation system so that
all you're all you are placing between
flights maybe apart from minor
maintenance is the
propellant
um I mean this is this like reusability
is so fundamental to uh to having a a a
a a a major change in space flight it's
would be difficult to overstate its
importance
um but I mean I think with analogy to
other modes of Transport you can imagine
that if airplanes could only be used
once um they would very few people would
fly um because it would be super crazy
expensive um you know guess like a 747
costs a quar billion dollars you'd need
two of them just for a round trip but
people are not paying half a billion
dollars to fly back and forth to London
um and that's because you can use 747
like 20,000 times um and for a rocket
you a falcon iron rocket
costs about $60 million to
build and so if you can use once
obviously that's a $60 million Capital
cost but if you can be used a thousand
times then it's only a $60,000 Capital
cost um and I mean that is you know it's
it is it is the fundamental difference
so you have to have fully usable then
you have to make sure that the
propellant used is uh as low cost as
possible so our next Generation Rockets
will be using methane as a fuel which
methane is the is the lowest cost Source
fuel on the planet um by by good margin
so
uh and so I I think if if if your
propellent cost is low and the system is
fully
reusable then I think it I think it
should be possible to it to move to Ms
for less than half a million dollars
which I think is is an important
threshold because if people can sell all
list on Earth and moveed to Mars well uh
and there's enough people who who can do
that um combined with those who actually
want to do that
uh then then that's that's the the
fundamental thing needed to uh have a a
growing Colony on Mars I mean kind of
like the way that the US was like the
early English colonies in America um
you when it became affordable for people
to sell all their stuff in England and
um move to America it grew really fast
um in the absence of that it would just
require humongous amounts of government
support and and I think probably
wouldn't be wouldn't result in a
self-sustaining civilization so the
economics of it are extremely
fundamental after that third
trip I I i' learned a lot more about
rockets at that point um and I I held a
series of meetings um just just sort of
brainstorming sessions with people from
the the space industry to try to
understand if there was if I was missing
something fundamental about um the
ability to improve rocketry um and this
is where I think it's helpful to use the
approach yeah the the anical approach in
physics which is to try to boil things
down to First principles and and reason
from there as opposed to reasoning by
analogy um
so and and the way this applied to to
rocketry was to say okay
well um what are the what are the
materials that that go into a rocket um
how you know how much does each material
constituent weigh um what's the cost of
that raw
material and and that and that's going
to set some floor um as as to the cost
of the rocket and and that actually
turns out to be a real small number um
certainly
um well under 5% of the cost of a rocket
and in some cases closer to 1 or
2% um and so I call sort of maybe the
the magic W number so if you if you had
a pile of of of of of the raw material
piles of raw materials on the floor and
you could just wave magic wand and
rearrange them um then then that would
be the the the best case scenario for
for a rocket and so I was able to see
okay well there's clearly a great deal
of room for improvement even if you
consider Rockets to be
Expendable um and and so so I think
that's that's sort of that's what I mean
by sort of thinking about things from a
first principal standpoint if if on the
hand other hand I sort of analyze it by
analogy and said okay well analogy would
be well what are all other rocket
companies what what do their Rockets
cost what historically have have other
Rockets cost and that would be sort of
an analogy thing but it really doesn't
illustrate what the true potential is
um and and so I I think sort of first
principle first principles approach is
is is a good way to um to understand
what new things are possible so this
this is a good a good framework how do
we figure out how to how to take you to
MOS um and and create a a
self-sustaining city a city that um is
not merely an outpost but could become a
planet in its own right um and PR thus
we could become a truly multiplet
species uh there you know sometimes
people wonder well what about other
places in the solar system why why
Mars um well um just to sort of put
things into perspective this is this is
what this is an actual scale of what the
solar system looks like so we're we're
currently in the the third Little Rock
from the left uh that's Earth um yeah
exactly the and and our goal is to go to
the fourth Rock on the left uh that's
Mars um but you can get a sense for the
real scale of the Soul system how big
the sun is and Jupiter um
Neptune Saturn Uranus and then the
little guys on on the right are Pluto
and friends this this sort of helps see
it not not quite to scale but it gives
you a better sense for for where things
are uh so our options for for going to
for for becoming a multiplet speci
within our solar system are uh are
limited uh we have in terms of nearby
options we've got Venus uh but Venus is
a high
pressure super high pressure hot Acid
Bath um so that that would be a tricky
one uh Venus is not at all like um the
goddess this is not in no way similar to
to to the actual goddess um so really
difficult to make things work on Venus
Mercury is also way too close to the
Sun um we could go potentially on the
mar one of the on the one of the moons
of Jupiter or Saturn but those are quite
far out much further from the Sun a lot
harder to get to it really leaves us
with one option if we want to become a
multi-planet civilization and that's
that's Mars um we could conceivably go
to our moon um and I certainly have
nothing against going to the moon but I
think it's it's challenging to create a
uh become multiplanetary on the moon
because it's it's much smaller than than
a planet it doesn't have any atmosphere
it it's not as resource rich as Mars um
it's got a 28 day day whereas the Mars
day is 24 and 1/2 hours um and in
general Mars is is far better suited to
ultimately scale up to be a
self-sustaining civilization when
you hire people or really what you're
trying to when you hire people that just
means you're convincing people to join
you in in the Endeavor ever um you
should hire people uh that are that also
passionate about what you're doing so
it's not just they're not just there for
the
salary um they really need to care about
what what they're doing and and then
then they will stay during the dark
times after that third
trip I I i' learned a lot more about
rockets at that point um and I I held a
series of meetings um just just sort of
brainstorming sessions with people from
the the space industry to try to
understand if there was if I was missing
something fundamental about um the
ability to improve rocketry um and this
is where I think it's helpful to use the
approach the the the anal approach in
physics which is to try to boil things
down to First principles and and reason
from there as opposed to reasoning by
analogy um
so and and the way this applied to to
rocketry was to say okay
well um what are the what are the
materials that that go into a rocket um
how you know how much does each matal
constituent uh weigh um what's the cost
of that raw
material and and that and that's going
to set some floor um as as to the cost
of the rocket and and that actually
turns out to be a relatively small
number um certainly
um well under 5% of the cost of a rocket
and in some cases closer to 1 or
2% um and so I call sort of maybe the
the magic W number so if you if you had
a pile of of of of of the raw material
piles of raw materials on the floor and
you could just wave magic wand and
rearrange them um then then that would
be the the the best case scenario for
for a rocket and so I was able to see
okay well there's clearly a great deal
of room for improvement even if you
consider Rockets to be expendable
um and and so so I think that's that's
sort of that's what I mean by sort of
thinking about things from a first
principal standpoint if if on the other
hand I sort of analyzed it by analogy
and said okay well analogy would be well
what are all other rocket companies what
what do their Rockets cost what
historically have have other Rockets
cost and that would be sort of an
analogy thing but it really doesn't
illustrate what the true potential is um
and and so I I think it's sort of first
principle
first principles approach is is is a
good way to um to understand what new
things are possible so this this is a
good a good framework why do you think
Tesla succeeded whereas other car
companies failed in their methods of
elect of electric cars like why do you
think Tesla is the leader in this
idea well um there haven't been that
many car companies start UPS uh I there
was sort of Fisker uh and Koda um and
and then a few smaller ones um and and
then the rest has sort of
been some some fairly small scale
efforts by the big
companies
um
uh I I I
think if if we say what the difference
between say Fisker and Tesla that's
maybe theit most direct comparison uh is
a hardcore engineering company and
visker is kind of a was based on kind of
on styling you know it's like styling is
good important but it's that's not the
reason we don't have electric cars so
it's not you know B for styling we we
would have electric cars that's not the
reason um so in the case of Visa they
made a car that uh a lot of people think
looked really good but didn't work
properly
so then people don't want to buy the car
um that's like a pretty reasonable thing
I think
um and yeah
um yeah I mean if you think like like
what what what's the point of a company
existing the the point is that it's it's
a group of people that have gathered
together to create a product if the
product is good the company should exist
and if it is not good the company should
not EX
um that seems like fundamental to the
nature of companies so the I mean
clearly then one should focus on making
the absolute best product you
can otherwise you reduce the probability
of success but a lot of companies focus
on things that aren't really to do with
the product um as though a company has
any basis for existing apart from doing
useful things that's kind of strange as
you called the the recession was
particularly difficult for for car
companies and right as in the summer of
2008 we had to raise a a big funding
round but because of the collapse in the
financial system that that funding round
didn't didn't happen and
um uh we had to piece together the money
to keep the company going from um myself
and existing investors and we were able
to just complete a to complete a
financing round that was just barely
enough to keep the company going
and we we closed it on the last hour of
the last day that it was possible to do
so uh it was a it was Christmas Eve uh
2000 2008 6:
p.m. and after that the investors would
would have had they were going on
vacation wouldn't have been possible to
bring them back to the table and we
would have run out of money a few days
after Christmas so that was also a close
call so while things are going really
well these days I think it's always
important to remember that when you're
creating a company there are very dark
times and it's about getting through
those those do times um that that's the
difference uh between success and
failure the proposed Mars Expedition
um what how exactly do you plan on
making it cost
efficient sure um well no that is that
is indeed a tricky problem
um
I mean I feel reasonably possible that
um that success is at least one of the
possible outcomes
um like this is a I mean this is pretty
important when you're trying to do
something it's like well can can that be
one of the outcomes I wasn't actually
confident about that until a few years
ago
um now I'm not saying we will get there
but I I I I I'm confident that it is at
least possible
um and the key to that is having a fully
reusable m transportation system so that
all you're all you are placing between
flights maybe apart from minor
maintenance is the
propellant
um I mean this is this like reusability
is so fundamental to uh to having a a a
a a a major change in space flight it's
would be difficult to overstate its
importance
um but I mean I think with analogy to
other modes of Transport you can imagine
that if airplanes could only be used
once um they would very few people would
fly um because it would be super crazy
expensive um you know I guess like a 747
cost a quar billion dollar you'd need
two of them just for a round trip but
people are not paying half a billion
dollars to fly back and forth to London
um
and that's because you can use 747 like
20,000 times um and for a rocket you
know a falcine
rocket costs about $60 million to build
and so if you can use once obviously
that's a $60 million Capital cost but if
you can be used a thousand times then
it's only a $60,000 Capital cost um and
I mean that is you it's it is it is the
fundamental difference so you have to
have fully use well then you have to
make make sure that the propellant used
is uh as low cost as possible so our
next Generation Rockets will be using
methane as a fuel which methane is the
is the lowest cost Source fuel on the
planet um by by good margin so
uh and so I think if if if your
propellent cost is low and the system is
fully
reusable then I think it I think it
should be possible to it to move to Mars
for less than half a million dollars
which I think is is an important
threshold because if people can sell all
their stuff on Earth and move to Mars
well uh and there's enough people who
who can do that um combined with those
who actually want to do that
uh then that then that's that's the the
fundamental thing needed to uh have a a
growing Colony on Mars I mean kind of
like the way that the US was like the
early English colonies in America
um you when it became affordable for
people to sell all their stuff in
England and um moved to America it grew
really fast um in the absence of that
it's it would just require humongous
amounts of government support and and I
think probably wouldn't be wouldn't
result in a self-sustaining civilization
so the economics of it are extremely
fundamental what drives you what what is
it that when you wake up in the morning
do you see a problem and you want to
solve it yeah
uh I I think the thing that drives me is
that uh I want to be able to think about
the future and uh you know feel good
about that um
so uh that uh you know we're doing what
we can
to uh have the future be be as good as
possible um to be inspired by what is
likely to happen um and to look forward
to the next day um
so that's that's what really really
drives me is is is trying to figure out
uh how do we how do we make sure that
things are great and um and going to be
so and um that's the underlying
principle behind Tesla and SpaceX
um is that um I think it's it's it's
pretty important that we accelerate the
transition to uh sustainable generation
and consumption of energy um it's it's
inevitable but it's it matters if we
have if it happens sooner or or later um
and then SpaceX is about um helping make
life
multiplanetary um and doing what we can
to continue the the dream of Apollo um
and um ultimately make contribution to
life becoming multiplanetary I think uh
you so so when you when you create a
company I mean if you think what is a
company really a company is a group of
people gathered together to create a
product or service and that that's
really what the company is and so you
have to really believe in what you're
creating and and that it's and and and
know in your heart and mind that this is
something that matters that and and and
that uh the world ought to have
um and I think it's important to
investors to to show that that you're
you're all in and I think for example
with with
Tesla um the the fact that I invested
all the money I had literally I had to
borrow money from friends to to pay the
rent in in 2008 um uh the fact so the
fact that I was all in I think was
hugely made a huge difference to to
investors um to convince them to invest
in in in Tesla uh at the same time that
that say GM and Chrysler were were going
bankrupt um and uh yeah I think like you
have to show that you you really care
like it's like you you um that you've
got skin in the game and
that you you've given it everything that
you've got and then the other people the
company uh will follow the suit as as
well investors I I think that's really
important another mistake that tends to
happen in production is too much
inprocess testing uh so in the when
you're first setting up a production
line you don't know where the like where
things are are breaking you don't know
where things are breaking so you'll test
uh like work in process at various steps
um and cuz you want to isolate where is
where are we where where's the mistake
occurring um so a very common mistake
issue with production lines is to have
um is to not remove the inprocess
testing uh after you've uh diagnosed
where the problems are so basically if
you have like um a very high acceptance
if like if if things are getting to End
of Line testing and and are passing uh
then you don't need to do inprocess
testing so uh but what tends to happen
is there'll be like an initial like
development engineering team that will
be like basically debugging the
production line but then they will
forget to take out the end process
testing
steps uh so then what happens is the
inprocess testing tester uh will often
choke the cycle time it choke choke the
line production time uh it'll be like
the limiter uh it will also have some
number of false positives and false
negatives uh but I mean like false
positives like then you're like
rejecting good parts right um so um
really in volume production if you have
if things are working well uh you're
really just taking a risk will this part
be will this sub system be rejected at
uh dur in the during the production
process or at the end um and so you just
really want to move things pretty much
almost always to just test at the end of
line and that's it um maybe there's like
one or two end process steps that are
hard to test at the end of line but that
but basically remove almost everything
an important thing in in uh Innovation
or trying to create new things is is is
to try really hard to to do that um
which may sound incredibly obvious but
uh that's what I find is is most often
what people don't do they actually
didn't didn't try super hard to come up
with something new um and and it is
helpful to have cross-pollination of
Industries
um I mean it's been quite difficult to
run SpaceX and Tesla but there has
been good ideas if since I got both in
my mind space this this good idea is
going back and forth the um for example
on the car with respect to the car the
model S is the only all aluminum body en
Chanty car made in North America and
very few cars are are all aluminum in
the airospace industry it's that that's
the default um so it seemed like like
obviously the right move in order to
minimize the the non battery packed mass
of the car so in order to offset you
know fairly heavy battery pack we had to
make the rest of the car light but but
still
achieve uh a five-star safety rating um
I don't think it would have been
possible to do that if we had used steel
which is the traditional method um and
and what's helped SpaceX has been that
the car industry is really good at
making complicated objects at a low cost
I mean it's actually quite incredible
that like one can
buy a decent car for 20 ,000 I mean all
the stuff that's in that car is I mean
it's nutty how much stuff is in a car
um so uh that at SpaceX uh I hired a
bunch of people from the Auto industry
to uh run manufacturing which has worked
out reasonably well what's the actual
biggest failure that you that you've
gone through to get to where you are we
blew up three rockets in the
beginning so
that
was that that was bad uh okay we
actually I only had enough money
originally I only I basically took all
all the money I made from PayPal put it
into SpaceX to creating SpaceX Tesla and
and solver City and uh initially figured
i' I just I'd keep half of it and then I
spend the other half on these crazy
Adventures that would probably fail um
and then unfortunately they needed all
the money
so so I had to give them all the money
and then I didn't have a house or had to
borrow money for rent that was that was
pretty difficult that was back in 2008
um and then we managed to scrape enough
spare parts together to do a fourth
launch at SpaceX um and that worked and
if it had not worked SpaceX would have
died probably would have lacked The
credibility to raise the remaining money
for Tesla and we wouldn't be here today
well maybe
like not this ending there's a lot of uh
technical problems to solve um so I
guess we sort of you know start studying
kind of engineering and physics and
biosciences and that kind of thing would
be the um way to go
um yeah um lot there going to be a lot
of problems to solve to to make a city
work on Mars
um we're thinking of just as a well sort
of a semi joke putting a uh job
description on our website for urban
planner in it's
Mars um but um you know this there's
going to be just tremendous amount of
problems to solve there'll be there's a
lot of building building and problem
solving so those are like the right you
know skills to work on if if if
someone's interested in going beyond
Earth or you know space in general I
think like if you're like trying to work
on something and like my experience is
like it's really hard to like if you're
trying to figure out what others love
but you don't love it it's really hard
to make that great so when you work on
something if you fall in love with it
that's that's a good sign um and then
don't worry about if others do if you do
others will whatever requirement or
constraint you have it must come with a
name not a department because you can't
ask the department you have to ask a
person uh and that person who's putting
forward the requirement of constraint
must agree that they must take
responsibility for that requirement
otherwise you can have a requirement
that basically an intern 2 years ago
randomly came up with off the cuff uh
and they not even at the company anymore
uh and and and but it came from the
let's say AA loads Department they're
like uh actually no one in the a loads
Department actually currently agrees
with that this is not this is by the way
happened several times so again it can
be literally on Theos Department there
like it's every Department first of all
I think that's pretty exciting and
inspiring and there need to be things
that are exciting and inspiring and uh
make you look forward to waking up in
the morning like it's like Yay future is
exciting this is
underappreciated you know like
tunnels sorry like all
right um and
um you know but there's got to be things
that make you excited about life um like
you can't just be problem solving you
know one one sort of miserable problem
after another it's got to be like I'm
fired up about the future and here's why
you know and and space is one of those
things that that does that for people
all around the
world um you know when um when Apollo 11
you know when when they landed on the
Moon I mean it was that was something
for all of humanity really was you know
people would you know if there's like
one TV for 50 miles around people would
walk you know they'd walk 50 miles just
to go find that one TV to to watch it
happen um so you know people think what
about what about poor nations of the
world like you know what Inspire
inspires them too um and um you know we
need things like
that because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all to the end and I love you so as a
special celebration if you put a hasht
believe down in the comments Below on
this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for 10 more amazing rules from Elon Musk
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the robot's just
the Ender factor in order for
civilization to advance uh we've got to
have freedom of I think in order to
really build trust you have to have
transparency it can't be that here Black
Box something's happening in here